[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight imagine how it must feel
to be baito or work right now if your if
your work you're out there running for
president really hard or at least
running for vice president you're
running anyway you're given speech after
speech every day children are our future
today is the first day of the rest of
your life
inspiring stuff like that deep stuff
like that and there's a physical
component to the job too
you're riding your skateboard for the
camera you're taking God knows how many
selfies for your fans on snapchat and
Instagram it's not an easy gig then one
morning you wake up and discover that
your one true love the American news
media have called it off
they've left you for a younger hotter
candidate when out for a pack of
cigarettes that just never came home
they split with some guy from Indiana
you can't even pronounce the guy's name
and there he was yesterday
front and center now third in the polls
with a speech that many upset or
historic he's inspirational so far and
that's that's something that that voters
absolutely want but he has this appeal
for a lot of reasons he is a veteran he
is openly gay he is from Indiana he is
honest he speaks from the heart he seems
like he's a lot about empathy here you
are concert pianist you speak many
languages including Norwegian that you
learned because you wanted to read a
book a real renaissance man he was like
Beto's smarter brother a little bit and
he's so smart to try to channel Obama
the second coming of Obama huh we'll see
about that
my prayers may have been answered if
that's true draw to this point has been
young fresh positive and a change agents
this guy is Chicken Soup for my soul
Chicken Soup for my soul even by the
naughty standards of the news media this
is a new level of political commitment
they don't just want to vote for this
guy they want to consume him like a
hearty stew every last drop of Buddha
judge young they're all in what's going
on here exactly who is this guy
there are a lot of liberals running for
president right now why would the 37
year old
the mayor of some third-string
Midwestern city no offense but that's
what it is why would that guy stand out
why is he more impressive and I don't
know senator Cory Booker or former
Governor John Hickenlooper or for that
matter any of the approximately eleven
thousand progressive Democrats running
for president at the moment why is this
guy better than them that's a pretty
tough question actually
we checked nobody knows least of all
Buddha judge himself his website gives
you his bio and then tells you how young
he is very young it says pretty much
nothing about what policies he might
support that's not an accident but we
can't just talk policy points all the
time Buddha judge said recently as
Democrats you have to figure out how to
tell a better story about our principles
and quote and actually that's not a
crazy point storytelling does matter but
first you have to know what your story
is you have to know what your principles
are and suddenly neither party knows
this they're not sure what they stand
for and that's really why things seems
so bizarre right now in this country
politically while they're so chaotic the
confusion is especially acute on the
Left we have to say because when your
only principle is gaining power well
you're out of luck you wind up elevating
people like Bernie Sanders who seem like
they're acting on principle but are just
the opposite here's one example Sanders
recently took fire from the left wing
think-tank Center for American Progress
cap noted the irony and it's real that
Bernie Sanders became a millionaire by
writing a book about how millionaires
are evil Sanders didn't like that
criticism last night he delivered this
response to it listen you've raised the
issue I am a millionaire well actually
this year we had five hundred and sixty
thousand dollars in income that's a lot
of money and that money in my case my
wife's case it came from a book that I
wrote pretty good book you might want to
read it
it's a best-seller sold all over the
world and we make money so if anyone
thinks that I should apologize for
writing a best-selling book I'm sorry
I'm not going to do it so the question
is not should you be allowed to write a
book the question is should you become a
millionaire doing it and Bernie says
yeah yeah if you want to become a
millionaire write your own bestseller so
Bernie's solution is what with me now
entrepreneurship just like Jack Kemp and
Ronald Reagan it's fine he's not
embarrassed about it neither were they
but let's not call it socialism let's
not tell the kids it's socialism it's
not socialism Bernie may think it is or
more likely he doesn't think that much
about anything maybe he's not capable of
it or doesn't care too or whatever how
else he explained this last night on
this channel Sanders seems completely
baffled when martha maccallum asked him
a very simple question the immigrants
being detained at the border where
should they be kept exactly watch this
the overflow that we have no capacity
for where do you think they should go
we need real comprehensive immigration
reform we don't need and let me say this
very clearly we don't need to demonize
immigrants
[Applause]
we have overflowing facilities they need
to go somewhere because they're in that
aside what about building where would
you put them what about building proper
facilities for them right now can be
done we're right on the water right on
the border at the same the people who
live on the border should have more
facilities in their states but sanctuary
cities which have said they're open to
accepting people should not take now
this is a political act it's not a real
question says Bernie Sanders keep in
mind Sanders is the front-runner in the
Democratic race for the nomination right
now and he's considered super impressive
at least a man of principle and depth
he's an intellectual you may not like
him but he's very smart
really so he was just ask where should
they be kept and he basically said well
nobody should be denied entry at the
border okay so where are they gonna stay
shut up that's not a real question don't
demonize immigrants pass comprehensive
immigration reform he reverts
immediately to talking points
it's not impressive it's buffoonish and
it's par right now in the Democratic
Party logical incoherence is practically
a campaign plank for example Democrats
are telling us that America sends too
many people to jail and they may be
right about that we sent a lot of people
to jail they're telling us we need to
let thousands of drug dealers out of
jail even though we're in the middle of
the worst drug epidemic in American
history they even got the White House to
sign on to that as you may have noticed
and so it's happening the legislation
passed and was signed and yet even as
thousands of criminals stream out to
freedom into voting which is always the
point at least one Democratic
presidential candidate Eric Schwaab
tells us we need to send a new class of
people back to prison mass incarceration
on a huge scale watch this criminal
prosecution for keeping assault weapons
what's the punishment for people who
don't hand in their guns do they go to
jail well they would but I also offer an
alternative which would be to keep them
at a hunting club or a shooting range
but I think the greatest threat to the
Second Amendment is doing nothing and
then second amendment is not an absolute
right yeah the greatest threat to the
Second Amendment is not sending millions
of law-abiding Americans to
prison after they've been reclassified
as felons overnight that's the real
threat so how was this gonna work
exactly how to swallow a plan to seize
all those weapons and imprison all of
those people and who's gonna fight on
his side during the civil war that
inevitably will result from this well we
have no idea and of course neither does
Eric's well he's just making noises he
thinks the left wants to hear that's
what they're all doing on every topic
they tell us the green New Deal is the
most important thing we can do it's more
important than the beaches at Normandy
it's more important than winning World
War two it's more important than putting
a man on the moon Neil Armstrong green
New Deal's in town now okay
so what's in the green New Deal nobody
knows they're making it up as they go
along
impeach Trump it must be done that steyr
character is taking a break from private
equity or whatever he does to devote his
life to impeaching Trump okay what are
the charges they don't know they don't
have any idea they can't even tell you
Democrats don't even know who's leading
their party right now
Alexandra Acacio Cortese says that she's
leading the party Nancy Pelosi scoffs
passively aggressively in response to
that she likes to minimize the conflicts
within her caucus between the moderates
and the progressives you have these
wings AOC and her group on one side side
side people yeah it's like five people
if only and by the way the divide is not
between the moderates and the
progressives there's nothing moderate
about Nancy Pelosi
there's nothing progressive about
Alexandria Acacio Cortes here's the real
division it's between equality which is
the traditional agenda of the Democratic
Party an agenda that cared about the
individual and the constitutional rights
that protected the individual and the
new wing of the Democratic Party which
news today and supposedly is bigger than
five people it's the identity politics
wing of the party identity politics is
the opposite of equality identity
politics preclude equality they make it
impossible in identity politics all
groups are not equal some are much
better than others some must be
stroyed that is not equality it's
permanent war so that's what's taken the
place of concerns about the individual
and you can see it even in the personal
behavior of the Democratic candidates
for president beta O'Rourke for example
turns out gave 1/3 of 1% of his total
income to charity last year one third of
1% he's a rich guy too
Kamla Harris also a rich person 1.4
percent to charity so why are these
people not being called out on this they
want to run the country would they give
nothing to charity well because they say
the right things that's why they check
the little identity politics boxes
they're against white privilege so it's
enough
except it's not enough this is not a
satisfying style of politics it doesn't
actually improve anyone's life it's not
working and the Democrats running for
president even though standing on the
sidelines no it's not working they're
going to lose to President Trump unless
they figure out a way to improve the
lives of actual people otherwise the
internal contradictions in this party
will become unbearable this is the party
of hedge fund managers and illegal
aliens what holds it all together
they have no idea until they find that
out it's going to fall apart